roughly six months ago the abuse of a
spectator bug
caused a massive coaching scandal and
rocked the cs go scene
three coaches were initially banned 37
coaches were eventually found guilty
and everybody had an opinion well
everyone except
valve but then last week valve dropped
one of their classic blog posts out of
the blue
and the thing that had everyone angry
and confused
valve straight up banned cs go coaches
well sort of
what's up fools we're on our way to 2
million subs and by scrolling down and
hitting that subscribe button
you can help us get there and if you
want to see more cs go videos like this
you might as well hit that notification
bell as well so buried at the bottom of
a blog post that valve dropped on a
random wednesday in january
is this bombshell quote during online
matches only players are allowed in the
room and on the server
neither coaches nor any other team staff
will be allowed in the room
on the server or to otherwise
communicate with the team
during an online match end quote banned
not just from the server
coaches can't even be in the same room
yeah valve just straight up destroyed
the coaching position in cs go for the
near future
now if valve just decided to ban coaches
from the server
fine it takes the option of accessing
the exploit off the table
i guess i still wouldn't agree but i'd
understand
but banning coaches from the room what
purpose does that
serve they can literally only see what
the players are
seeing what does this move actually
accomplish
there's also this to think about if
you're moses with liquid
yanko with faze clan or any other coach
with a tier one org that's backed by a
gigantic multinational corporation
your job is probably safe what about
those smaller orgs with teams in just a
few esports
do they just lose their jobs immediately
various cs pros
analysts and personalities recognized
the impact
that valve's decision would have on the
sea here's hltv's confirmed podcast
discussing the news
and when we shifted online there was a
lot of debate about this do we have
coaches do we not have coaches
do the coaches get to talk the whole
time what if coaches are in a separate
team speak and
all the players in a separate team speak
so the coach is talking the whole time
how do we monitor this how do we monitor
that
in particular eg's coach zeus was
extremely vocal
and said that he and the majority of
coaches are essentially being banned
from doing a big part of their job
for something they didn't even do now we
managed to sit down with him for an
interview
here's what he had to say about valve's
latest decision
when all of this news comes out like it
was already a pretty big hit on the
scene with everything
but i do put that a lot on the coaches
that
abused this bug and did everything and
valve signs behind
when on e6 ruling
they are saying that isek is correct and
banning them and they're supporting them
so
you already punished everyone that was
doing wrong why are we just punishing
the ones that haven't done something
wrong now this decision that's
essentially going to reshape parts of
the cs go scene
was kickstarted by a short report
published by esl in late august
which found hard legion's mechanogun
mibr's
dead and heroics hunden all guilty of
abusing an
in-client spectator bug and then on
september 28th
the esports integrity commission or esic
published a report that found 37 coaches
guilty of abusing the same
exploit and the cs go scene exploded
all over again we covered the
controversy at the time
so yeah this coaching exploit as it's
being called basically allows a coach to
place themselves anywhere on the map
and then swivel their camera from side
to side and theoretically take any info
that they gather from that
and give it to their players now valve
did post a statement about the coaching
exploit in early september
and stated that quote any teams that
were disqualified for exploiting this
bug during an rmr event
will have their rmr points reset end
quote rmr if you didn't know
is the regional major ranking system
that valve implemented for the rio major
that was supposed to happen in november
but got cancelled due to coven
rmr essentially replaced the old miner
invite system if you pay attention to cs
go you've probably heard about this
coaching scandal a million times by now
including the fact that esic isn't done
with their investigation
that initial report only included 20
of the data that they had compiled but
then things died down for a while
and cs go continued to chug along online
and honestly nobody was surprised that
valve hadn't said anything
substantial yet and valve dropping this
news in a random blog post in january
isn't surprising either
hell it's pretty much the only way valve
delivers news
also people weren't surprised valve came
down as hard as they did
first i buy power then the coaching
changes in 2016.
now this it's what valve does
speaking of which 2016 was when valve
made their first
big changes to how the coaching position
worked at the time they changed the
rules from pretty much unlimited
communication between coaches and
players
to coaches only being able to interact
with the roster during pre-game warm-up
time-outs and in-between maps the
problem valve said
is that the coach was effectively a
sixth player
and quote since the goal of our events
is to identify
the best five-player teams that exhibit
the best combinations
of all cs skills the current
participation of coaches in the game
is not compatible with that goal end
quote similar to now
players coaches and analysts freaked out
and called this
the death of the coaching position as we
knew it here's what zeus had to say
about the 2016 coaching changes
i don't want to like hate on valve
because i do think that some of the
changes that they've done in regards to
coaches
even though extreme were in the right
direction but maybe they overdid it
right
and i did feel that as coaches we had a
little bit too much freedom especially
when we're on stage and
we're 24 7 unmuted through the live
rounds through everything that's going
on
in arenas and everything so i felt that
there was justification to how they were
treating it but
as always they overdid it in china it
was complete
180 and the whole situation was like no
you're not going to talk anymore at all
that's it not even attack pauses you're
kind of done for
and in typical valve fashion they've
essentially banned
coaches without laying down any new
infrastructure
like can coaches come back into the room
at half
or during timeouts can they still prep
the team during pre-game warm-ups and
then leave
and how does this change the igl
position which essentially acts as the
coach in-game
do they now have to take on even more
responsibility
we don't have any answers to these
questions because once again
valve is being frustratingly vague about
one of the biggest
esports on the planet it's also worth
mentioning that
if cs go moves forward with the lan
major scheduled for october
it doesn't necessarily mean we're over
with the online era of cs go
the odds are the online era is going to
continue
well after the major and if that happens
it's back to coaches being glorified
analysts
until valve says otherwise but i think
it makes it harder and it actually goes
against what they're trying to do as
it opens up more avenues for things to
be done
in this in this shady area at least and
i don't think that's good for anyone
especially for the competitive integrity
that we all want
now there's been a new development since
valve dropped that blog post
on tuesday blast premiere announced that
coaches will be able to communicate with
players
in that essentially valve's ruling won't
apply for the blast premier spring
groups this news might not seem that
important but
considering that for a long time valve's
word was
law blast premier going against that
word
could be a sign that things are changing
if valve lets this happen
it could set an interesting precedent
for other to's
challenging valve's typically ironclad
rulings
and the counter-strike scene celebrated
blast premier's decision online
and i think blast coming out and
supporting us i think it's a huge shout
out to them but
i think the way they're approaching it
is the way i'd advise all other to
approach it is
control more the environment and i don't
say this only in regards to coaches
on top of banning coaches from being in
the room or being on a server
valve also followed up to the statement
they made in september
regarding e6 investigation quote as
our follow-up we have decided that
coaches that exploited the camera bug
will be ineligible to participate in
some number of future valve sponsored
events
that number to be determined by the
extent of the abuse end quote
the blog post then shows a chart
equating the number of esic demerit
points
with the number of valve sponsored
events guilty coaches will have to miss
and this demerit point system was rolled
out by esic back in september
here's how it works more than two cases
of abuse would attribute to three
demerit points to the offending party
two cases of abuse would attribute two
demerit points to the offending party
and one case of abuse would attribute
one demerit point to the offending party
in respect to duration of abuse more
than 50 rounds of abuse
would attribute to five demerit points
to the offending party
more than 20 rounds of abuse would
attribute three demerit points to the
offending party
more than seven rounds of abuse would
attribute two demerit points to the
offending party
and less than seven rounds of abuse
would attribute one demerit point to the
offending party now
e6 said that they would make their
demerit point calculations
available to the public as soon as they
were finished but
if you look at e6 list of who abused the
bug and for how long
and compare it to the amount of demerit
points they're likely to have
based on that list here's who could be
permanently banned
from all valve sponsored events apoca
biggie bruno finn prd
region twista and meccano gun and again
i say
could be banned because neither valve or
isik
have stated specifically which coaches
meet that six point demerit threshold
here's zeus on the demerit point system
and e6 investigation as a whole
my initial reaction was kind of sharp
because i did everything correctly i
remember when the
valve bug was actually go the whole
scandal was going on i was actually even
behind the scenes i posted on twitter
i'm like
i think this happens when coaches join
first in the server or something like
that so
i'm actually trying to help fix the
situation and now i read that our
valve rmr points are reset so we were
guaranteed legends now not anymore and i
can't help my team
win anymore seeing as everyone that's
done their part of malicious activities
has been caught has been punished and
valve has signed behind it
i just felt like i was getting the bad
end of a stick here of
something that i didn't deserve so there
you have it another instance of valve
just
casually blowing up cs go while
continuing their routine of not
providing
nearly enough information to those
impacted by its decision will valve come
to its senses and clarify when coaches
will be able to do their jobs again
or will orgs be forced to adapt like
they have in the past
i'd like to say that we'll know soon but
it's valve
so who knows the coaching position isn't
the strongest
we always say we're the weakest link
because we're not inside the server
we're not we can't get up the next day
just prove our worth inside the server
because i can be doing
something really badly and if i tomorrow
i show up that's it but in our position
we're not we're never allowed that
benefit
so maybe in my position it only hurts a
paycheck or a future negotiation or
something like that
but smaller organizations who rely on
these
coaches to not only teach their the ones
that they have it's kind of how to set
the bar
and how to go with i know how much a
sticker can be worth for a new work i
know how much
a coach getting into the major can be
can change and
if they don't see the as much bang for
buck in the product that they're
investing maybe they try to go for just
the player and that if that's what valve
wants that's great but
again it's going against their intent
because the tier one orgs they have
they're gonna have the coast they're
going to have the analysts they're going
to have everything
then you're really just taking the
general public and the lower chances of
actually starting
to have an honest chance of competing
and making the prestigious event
prestigious events that people want the
major to be the blog post then shows a
tour
a twart what's a twart even if we move
forward with the on
even if we move forward with the major
land
forward it's all
[Laughter]
what i just got the giggles you know
that's all